[Music]
very vividly the CCP's
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive uncle Joey's back in your [ __ ]
world for everything's gonna be fine
understand me it's great to see you
[ __ ] November 2nd 2016 was just
[ __ ] January 8th we were jumping up
and down the [ __ ] time flies quick
[ __ ] a lot of things happen to
know Velma what the prison I kid that
Bell oh yeah
a lot of bad things is happening a
November November's not my lucky is
[ __ ] month but I did do something nine
years ago this month that changed my
[ __ ] world I stopped getting [ __ ]
high this month will be nine years since
I've done a good [ __ ] line of coke
looked out windows worried about this
benign [ __ ] years I thought I could
never even wait for a [ __ ] week nine
years do you know what's happened in
nine years
Joey what's with the cheddar child or
nor did you talk I want to set the
birdman free that's most American we'll
check channel all the way
nine years ago was living at a studio
problem of my wife with nine cats and no
[ __ ] prospects nine years ago [ __ ]
four or five six grands week broke
bouncing checks the whole [ __ ] deal
nine [ __ ] years ago nine [ __ ]
years ago
I stopped doing the [ __ ] powder I
focused on my life and I married that
[ __ ] kid comley's [ __ ] great my
health is [ __ ] great
yeah I'm sayin it all starts with one
[ __ ] just one all I stopped was doing
blow and everything off brother if I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay we all know I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if I could do it
could you imagine what you [ __ ]
could do with parents and white people
support you and your friends this [ __ ]
really I'm saying I'm a [ __ ] mutt and
I could do it do you imagine what you
could [ __ ] do that's all I'm just
putting it out there just in case you're
having a ho-hum day you can't stop
eating pills you can stop sucking pigs
football whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
there's an end game there's an end day
but it all depends do you late today you
know you're sick and tired of being a
[ __ ] money
that's it I'm breaking these shackles
brother I'm getting a [ __ ] BB gun a
[ __ ] headlight I'm going out there
and that's what you need to do and
everything will change but it all starts
with you you know I'm saying but anyway
here we are smoking to the best weeds in
California I got my [ __ ] hard boy
always from perennial you know me I'm a
loyal [ __ ] custom everyone's know why
I go to bones and whatever bones and
roses whatever up in Sherman Oaks if I'm
up that way they got some great reefer
but it but I'm local I'm just trying to
save time I hid perennial or the [ __ ]
Russians over the Armenians that son
said earlier for stars it that want to
give a shout-out to my main man
[ __ ] Gino listen you need some
stars ball speed weed [ __ ] I
don't have the stars they're within
minutes those [ __ ] or how a
compliment to you you know I'm saying
contact speed weep tell Gino I [ __ ]
say [ __ ] maybe it'll give you like a
Spectre or something that you smell his
finger
I love smoking reefer you [ __ ]
having seen you in a few days I've been
a little box a little busy but we're
back today we're back like [ __ ] I
don't know I don't even know what I'm
backward I'm just happy to be around my
[ __ ] reefer family
we're gonna have a great [ __ ] week
this week you got rafael dos anos
I got el Cucuy with that good fights
this weekend next weekend Friday and I
Boston [ __ ] whatever will but day
that's old I think I like [ __ ] 20
tickets left and they're all singles you
gotta sit next to [ __ ] dudes with
three eyes but Saturday night I'm at
Foxwoods through here in the area just
come in to Foxwoods and they're gonna
have the [ __ ] UFC fight there so we
could do it all at [ __ ] once who is
better than you [ __ ] Joey what's with
the chitter chatter want to spark this
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with joy bananas
yeah the ones are back doctor police's
in town get your breathing on she's
doing like a certification this week if
you're around you learn how to breathe
the [ __ ] tilde she'll teach you how to
breathe underwater like [ __ ] not a man
oh I can feel the THC entering my
[ __ ] heart my ballsack so I can have
a tremendous [ __ ] date today that's
right I'm a [ __ ] emotional [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] what you gotta say but
you know what I smoked reefer but I see
the color I see everything is beautiful
I can see Isis hide that the [ __ ]
treat that's what happens when you smoke
reefer you understand but anyway what
were we I don't even [ __ ] know
I'm already stoned I don't know if I'm
doing a podcast today and I tell you
what cuz it's the world [ __ ]
series okay this is a national fight
this is a Game seven
this Chicago against Cleveland you gotta
respect [ __ ] Chicago that's why I
take my special actors they're [ __ ]
animals
and you gotta respect Cleveland cuz
that's another city of [ __ ] animals
I'll be up there with you [ __ ]
January 12th the bitter [ __ ] can call
them come to Cleveland you know why cuz
I don't [ __ ] around anyway that's why
I'm not doing the practice I'd do it in
the afternoon but I got a meeting at
3:00 I got you jet 2 at 12 I got a lot
of [ __ ] going on so we'll just do the
podcast tomorrow this one time and we'll
talk a little baseball we'll talk a
little s we'll talk about that and as
usual eat some [ __ ] THC and we smoke
some reefer and whatever you want to
talk about you don't need though my
heart's an open [ __ ] book just gonna
show up like bounnam's
that's all my ass if you read about mr.
me - [ __ ] off
you know I'm saying don't even breathe
on the [ __ ] screen cuz I can smell it
[ __ ] [ __ ] garbanzo bean [ __ ]
and your mouth your [ __ ] anyway look at
this [ __ ] thing I let these [ __ ]
things get dries I'm gonna get out
my [ __ ] Teresa family right there
it's good to see you [ __ ] you
brightened my [ __ ] day today I hadn't
seen you guys oh yeah
shit's goin on let's [ __ ] sometimes you
recall [ __ ] marijuana you know I show
up [ __ ] Oh a minute before I show off
wind blows behind my [ __ ] back and
you get up like Jesus Christ this guy's
been smoking reefer with a [ __ ] out
to the bus today we think one more
belong and no rush
it's do which Wednesday what the [ __ ]
you got to do you already proved you're
going for the week yeah but is it 9:30
that means it's 12 o'clock 12:30 in the
East Coast that said Lisa I asked coming
[ __ ] Boston we're gonna have a good
old time legal seafood you know it's old
I don't even like I'm too [ __ ]
excited when I come up to the Northeast
oh I think about his lobsters [ __ ]
yeah reefer and [ __ ] to smell his
ships and Quincy mass and [ __ ] like that
yeah I'm saying
Joey which with the jelly chatter light
up another [ __ ] woman
it's like I was talking November's
always been like that Marilyn Martinez
died this month I'm inside the rear 50
[ __ ] years at all on this month lot
of [ __ ] happen in my life November so
but I just was thinking about in the
shower this might be nine [ __ ] years
you guys have no idea what the condition
I wasn't I wasn't bad as 84 84 I was
addicted in a week in 2007 I was just
addicted and heartbroken I didn't know
what it was the more drugs I did the
more heartbroken I got it so I don't
know I don't know why this happened but
I'm happy I got cleaned from the [ __ ]
cocaine because you know what we would
have never [ __ ] back how's that
looking for you that's it and that's
that you know I love you [ __ ]
I'll let you know I Twitter it up do
like we do a church that I periscope but
all right you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart never
forget that [ __ ] without you and have
[ __ ] then who would sell out the
[ __ ] Wilbur theater that I'm a piece
of [ __ ] you guys completed me man that's
why smoke-free for you that's why I come
out here and tell you what the [ __ ]
crack-a-lackin'
all right I don't take care of some [ __ ]
I love you cut this up to stay black
keep your eyes open I remember that
don't you nine years a lot of this [ __ ]
could happen on the other side stay
black